welcome to this video and playing the
fur time one hundred percent score
against him c5 maybe you get amarok see
bind again really don't mind that no he
doesn't want to yeah so this is a king's
indian with a strange night on a five
but that line isn't that bad so 93 I
guess so that I have f4 f5 let's see is
this really possible oyster some tactic
on the diagonal and no I don't think so
so let's go ahead for typical way of
playing this and cheeks hmm g6 is
hanging and e6 is hanging so so Teague's
and 96 horses too simplistic maybe it is
but let's let's do that I usually who I
usually should go for the relatively
simple continuation and normally favors
my my type of game to not make it to two
wild and crazy
I just want to put the knight on d5 and
claim an edge like that hmm Queen your
form
yeah but its Queen D for such a big deal
to take c4
hmm tricky business the diagonal with
some checks on IG phone booths also
tricky
he's got ideas that Queen D for chick is
annoying really
okay I didn't really calculate that more
so much I just hope it works night-night
c4i maybe you can really take that
somehow i forgot about 90 on over there
see the position here let take some tech
some things simultaneously
this hangs think you'd probably have to
take anyway and now this is hanging and
if one is hanging check rook e8 hmm i
don't have a great move now I think
Queen a for something or other Queen
moves 95 I evil he can take a one he
really can do that
whoopsie one Bishop c3
it just doesn't work it just does not
work time morning yeah i know but i
don't see don't see a play will move wow
what a bad game could be irritated me to
no end with this stuff the I'm doing it
can I get somewhere I can get Quincy to
maybe an attacking g6 and this is at
least maybe somewhat interesting maybe I
can probably just play book e7 again
Queen g6 then he can play hook g7 and no
problems
not just lost him two points down rookie
seven wins we had yeah maybe 96 was was
wrongly timed I didn't need to do that
quickly I could have delayed that move
probably prepared with Luke c1 or
something yeah now he's taking time
nobody knows why have to do that
unfortunately but maybe you play some
weird moves in the end game you never
know even though it's a complete loss
here
check
now it doesn't really make any stupid
mistakes in the end game the shadow claw
get dry that's very easy to claim white
resides here not good not good man it
was a weird position jinx jinx may I
should have gone there immediately yeah
this is I took to be honest I just
forgot that he can take see for that was
my issue I just forgot that you can take
that pawn ok this is the move that I
should play according to the computer
but what I don't quite understand this
oh yeah so this is what the engine gives
chechik and i thought this chatty
possible but of course it's not the
cessation and white wins is the name
here yeah that will realign that as song
not that I window I thought that 93
would be would be the issue and this is
not working at all you to nudge for that
also so I really forgot that C phalanx
and then he just wins I mean it's just
checked it just like that there's
nothing yeah yeah just just 11 mistake
but that costs the game that we should
be three more costs that
it's really like that it's just dumb a
case where 95 and leads to them to a
clear advantage and the other moves
loose and I didn't didn't see that
correctly what is the engine giving then
has the best cat takes Queen chicks 98
yeah well then we're talking about that
wind straightaway and e6 this let's
close to winning that's hard to believe
that black can play like that night to
be seven and weakening himself and so on
but Dad you have to be precise I just
forgot about the c-4 born and this is
again it's the whole game down we should
be three that one move okay thanks for
watching